مطالب الرئيس الاوكراني الملحى بخصوص
الدبابات الغربيه بدات تاتي بثمارها الى
جانب دبابات ليبرتي اثنين الالمانيه وابرز
الامريكيه و تشالنجر 2 البريطانيه اعين
نوكياف ايضا تتوجه صوب دبابات لوكلاغ
الفرنسيه دبابات قتاليه ثقيله يصل وزنها
الى 65 طنطا سهله الحركه محصنه جيدا
البنادق عليها ثابته حتى عند قياده
الدبابه بسرعه 50 كم في الساعه ولا يحتاج
رقمها الا لثلاثه رجال على عكس الدبابات
الاخرى رئيس الفرنسي في مؤتمر الصحفي مع
المستشار الالماني قبل يومين قال انه لا
يستبعد احتمال ارسال دبابات لوكلاغ الى
اوكرانيا بشرتي الله يصعد ذلك من شده
المعركه وان لا يعرض امن فرنسا للخطر
مستبعدا لكن يجب احترام ثلاثه معايير
الاول الا يكون هناك تصعيد وهو ما نحرص
عليه منذ البدايه والثاني هو ان يوفر ذلك
دعنا حقيقيا وفعلا لاصدقائنا الاوكرانيين
واحداث فريق على الارض يقول الخبراء
العسكريون انه يجب ارسال 100 دبابه على
الاقل هذا يعني تخلف فرنسا عن نصف
الدبابات المتاحه لديها حاليا والجاهزه
للقتال اذا عددها لا يتقطم 220 دبابه وهو
عدد اقل بكثير من دبابات ليبرتي اثنين
الالمانيه التي يفوق مخزونها ثلاثه الاف و
500 دبابه منذ 2008 توقف انتاج دبابات في
باريس هلاليه